have you ever noticed when a bilingual
person switches languages it can often
seem like their voice itself is also
changing like they're not only stringing
together sounds in a different way but
that many of the sounds you'd think
would be the same across languages
seemingly aren't this phenomenon gave me
a lot of trouble when I began learning
Japanese but probably even more trouble
when I began teaching Japanese people
would ask me why this happens but I
would struggle to answer because this
isn't just an issue of pitch accent and
it's also not just an issue of
pronunciation as we're typically taught
it I.E where you need to put your tongue
how open your mouth needs to be how
round your lips need to be Etc It's a
combination of these things as well as
several other factors that can be very
difficult to put your finger on without
some Advanced linguistic knowledge I
initially tried to teach this topic
using the linguistic knowledge that I
picked up at University as well as some
other resources that I I picked up after
graduating but found that it often
backfired this is because the variables
that contribute to this phenomenon such
as fundamental speech frequency can
often require their own lengthy
explanations and these explanations can
then further require a list of caveat
ODS when you start trying to integrate
them all together into a coherent
framework so my initial lessons on this
topic were a bit bloated and hard to
follow especially for beginners
essentially no one was saying Oh okay
that's what's happening now I get it
that's really helpful but I didn't want
to abandon the topic entirely because in
my opinion having an even base
understanding of the phenomenon can help
a lot with one preventing a lot of bad
habits from forming and two learning to
pick up on and subsequently
unconsciously mimic a lot of things that
otherwise can take
sometimes years to even start noticing
so I scrapped all of my initial videos
on this topic and tried approaching
things from a fundamentally different
angle and that's what this lesson is
this is episode 5.1 of my patreon series
Japanese phonetics in its entirety and
in this video I try and approach this
voice shift phenomenon in not the most
precise or academic way but in a way
that I like to believe is easy to follow
and more importantly actually practical
for beginner and intermediate Learners I
tried to make the video that I would
have wanted to have when I started
learning about this topic many years ago
I'm releasing this lesson for a few
reasons one because again I like to
think that it would be very beneficial
for a lot of people two because I'm a
dad the holidays are coming I'm getting
busy but I got to keep on appeasing the
YouTube algorithm and three because
Japanese phonetics is currently 16% off
annual subscriptions this is the biggest
discount we've ever given for annual
subs and it will be until the end of the
year I thought the best way to convince
people to come on over would be to
release a proper sample to the public so
that's what this is I'll be adding a
couple of related points on this topic
after the L is over but for now uh
probably best to just let the video
speak for itself so let's jump
in hi everyone and welcome to episode
5.1 of Japanese phonetics by dogen in
this lesson we'll be looking at how the
typical Japanese voice and speaking
style is different from that of the
typical American English voice and
speaking style first of all what do I
mean by voice and what do I mean by
speaking style when I say voice in this
lesson I'm talking about a person's
speech organs so their throat their
tongue their nasal cavity Etc now you
obviously can't fundamentally change
your speech organs but you can change
how you use them and this is what I mean
by speaking style in this lesson
speaking style refers to a speaker sort
of default settings for their speech
organs as well as their General mood or
even Vibe when speaking a specific
language and this is what we'll be
spending the rest of the lesson on how
Japanese speaking style is different
from English speaking style I believe
that after studying for long enough most
people get a sort of feel for how
Japanese speaking style is different
from English speaking style that said
this process can often take months if
not years especially if you're going
through a typical Japanese classroom
course I think this is primarily because
most Learners are never given the
opportunity to very easily compare
Japanese speaking Style with English
speaking style it would help a lot if we
could could hear one speaker switch
between the two Styles and it would help
even more if we could hear one speaker
demonstrate the two Styles but for the
exact same word or phrase and that's
what we're going to do now we're going
to listen to a single native Japanese
speaker who went to the NHK
pronunciation school is also fluent in
English and has experience with this
topic switch between the two speaking
Styles but in one language first we'll
hear her say the English phrase you look
tired in Japanese speaking style then
we'll hear her say the exact same phrase
but with English speaking style now some
of the differences between the two
speaking styles are very small so I
would encourage everyone watching to try
and listen in a quiet room with good
headphones I'll give everyone a second
here to
prepare are you ready first we'll hear
three recordings of the Japanese
speaking style slow slow and then normal
speed then we'll hear through recordings
of the English speaking Style again in
the same manner and then we'll hear the
two Styles back to back okay let's try
listening you look
[Music]
tired you look
tired
you look
tired you look
[Music]
tired great now that we've compared the
two Styles back to back for an English
phrase let's try and do the same thing
for a Japanese phrase the speaker will
now now say this I want to go to Japan
in Japanese like before we'll hear the
Japanese speaking style the
English-speaking style and then we'll
hear the two Styles said back to back
Okay let's
listen
okay so what have you noticed how do the
two speaking Styles feel different for
you everyone will obviously describe the
differences between the two speaking
Styles in different ways but I like to
summarize things in the following way
Japanese speaking style is similar to
Japanese culture it is clearly defined
consistent and orderly American English
speaking Style on the other hand is
similar to American culture it is
relaxed flexible and free again Japanese
speaking style clearly defined
consistent and orderly an American
speaking Style relaxed flexible and free
now I realized that probably sounds very
vague and unhelpful so now we're going
to explore some concrete differences
between the two speaking Styles we're
going to explore in detail how switching
speaking Styles can cause the same word
or phrase to sound fundamentally
different let's start with air flow in
the Japanese speaking style the amount
of air being exhaled throughout the
phrase is fairly regular and constant
again consistent and orderly on the
other hand the English speaking style is
more relaxed and flexible and as a
result of this the speaker slows down a
little bit relatively speaking toward
the end of the phrase and when the
speaker slows down the amount of air
traveling through her throat slows down
as well which causes just a bit of
creaky Voice or sometimes known as vocal
fry that a sound to occur at the end of
the phrase try listening one more time
noticing how the breathiness of the
Japanese style stays more or less
constant from beginning to end while in
the english- speaking style things are
less consistent which results in just a
bit of vocal fry at the end of the
phrase you look
[Music]
tired you look
tired you look tired
you look
tired you look
tired so just by saying things in a
slightly more relaxed or undecided
manner we end up introducing a
fundamentally different vocal quality to
our speech interesting right here's
another example as we learned in lesson
five timing in Japanese is usually
measured not with syllables but with
Mora and generally speaking in Japanese
each one of these MOA or beats has the
same set length again things are
consistent however if you speak in a
relaxed flexible manner it can become
difficult to maintain this timing for
example if I say the word for cute kalai
with the correct pitch accent but with
English speaking style I might end up
sort of just trailing off at the end as
in
kalai again as opposed to ending right
on time more like Kawaii try comparing
the two back to back with Native
speech
Kaw
[Music]
Kawaii
Kawai
[Music]
kawaii
kawaii now it's not as if speakers never
Trail off or use creaky voice for that
matter in Japanese because they
certainly do it's that if the situation
is the same native Japanese speakers
will typically speak in a more defined
consistent and orderly manner than
native English speakers and that as a
result of this generally speaking there
is less trailing off and creaky voice in
Japanese okay one final example vowels I
talk about this in lesson 37 but in the
Japanese word for love which is spelled
like this each of the vowels are
articulated one after the other as in I
I this makes it sound very different
from the English word i i in which the
two vowels are said as a DI thong or a
sound in which one vowel kind of morphs
into another one try comparing the two
back to back again taking note of how in
Japanese each of the vowels are clearly
articulated while in English the
boundary between the two is much less
clear
I
I so once again the Japanese speaking
style is more defined consistent and
orderly and remember it's not as if you
can't say I in a relaxed manner because
you certainly can it's that you'll
probably have an easier time saying I
and other Japanese words and phrases in
a natural manner with less of an English
accent if you try to generally speak in
a clearly defined consistent and orderly
way all right so we've seen how changing
speaking Styles can affect airf flow
timing and vowels there are many more
things that speaking style can affect
but I strongly believe that rather than
trying to pinpoint and address every one
of these individually it's much better
at least initially to try and get a
general feel for the Japanese speaking
style thus I'd like to end this lesson
by listening to a few more backtack
recordings of Japanese and English
speaking Style again this may come
across as a bit vague but the important
thing here is to get a general feel for
how the two Styles differ okay are you
ready let's
listen good
morning good
morning
Hi how are
you Hi how are
[Music]
you Hi how are you
I like my
job I like my
job so how did it go are you starting to
get a feel for the defined consistent
and orderly Japanese speaking style
naturally there are many exceptions to
this speaking style that I talk about
later in the series such as devoicing n
becoming Etc but again generally
speaking your Japanese will sound much
more natural if you try to speak in a
clearly defined consistent and orderly
manner this is especially true if you
come from an American English background
in which people tend to speak in a very
relaxed flexible and free way starting
today try and pay attention to speaking
style you'll almost certainly start to
notice immediately major differences
between Japanese speaking style and
American English speaking style and once
you start to notice these differences
your ability to unconsciously and
naturally replicate Japanese speaking
style will improve dramatically all
right guys that's all for this episode I
hope that you found it useful for the
next lesson of Japanese phonetics please
see the link below this video thank you
all very much for your continued support
and I look forward to speaking with you
again
soon all right so that's the lesson I
hope that you guys found it useful some
of of you may have noticed this but the
speaker in this video while 100% fluent
in both languages and again very
knowledgeable on this topic she wasn't
brought up in a bilingual environment so
there might have been a couple of
instances in which her not 100% native
English pronunciation was contributing
to the differences in speaking style but
I still think that she does an excellent
job of illustrating the general kind of
the macro differences between standard
Japanese speaking style and again
American English speaking style one
final thing I'd like to mention I kind
of said this in the video multiple times
but never explicitly so I'd like to do
so now and this is that language is not
just speaking listening reading and
writing it's also character and culture
that is to say if you have two people
who have identical pitch accents and
pronunciation and speaking Styles but
one of them uses more Japanese
mannerisms and has kind of a
stereotypical Japanese personality so
maybe they're generally humble and
agreeable that person's Japanese in most
circumstances is going to come come
across as more natural to native
speakers despite the fact that the
sounds themselves are identical I think
that when we see a completely bilingual
speak or switch languages because we're
typically taught to concentrate on the
sounds when it comes to language we
become conscious of the differences in
speaking style maybe even if we aren't
able to articulate what those
differences are and then also we're
unconscious of the smaller differences
in the way that the speaker might hold
themselves based on the differences in
the two culture where that language came
from and then I think what happens is we
kind of attribute all of these
differences to voice we say that
person's voice itself changed or
sometimes we say personality like that
person's personality changed and this is
kind of the point that I'm trying to
make that language doesn't exist in a
vacuum that it's inherently linked to
the culture that it comes from and that
because of this the more Japanese that
you are across the board the more
natural every single individual aspect
of your Japanese including your spoken
Japanese will seem of course you
shouldn't change your personality to the
point where it becomes uncomfortable and
there are many exceptions to the
guidelines that we just learned about in
the same way that there are many
Japanese people who aren't particularly
humble or agreeable but if you become
conscious of the general trends of
spoken Japanese as well as the general
Trends and characteristics of Japanese
culture especially early on that can
help tremendously so once again Japanese
is generally spoken in a defined
consistent and orderly manner and in
Japan it's generally favorable to act in
a humble and agreeable way when you put
these two things together that can
account for a whole lot of that voice
shift all right again Big Discount off
of annual subscriptions to Japanese
phonetics if you found this video
helpful you'll probably find the rest of
the series helpful as well so please
consider signing up comedic video coming
soon
s